et aujourd'hui on a eu une très mauvaise
nouvelle parce que quelqu'un nous a
quittés c'est ariane du club dorothée
que j'aimais énormément qui était venu
nous voir d'ailleurs ici dans touche pas
à mon poste
alors c'est vrai qu'on a bousculé voilà
le 20h10 de l'émission parce qu'on
voulait absolument en parler et revoir
des images d'elle dans le club dorothée
on a demandé à jacky de venir nous voir
merci jacques initiatique qui a
travaillé avec avec ariane beaumont des
années oui pendant un temps 10 ans
aurait craint de 10 ans elle est décédée
hier elle avait 61 ans
c'était moi je l'avais en jeu le
rencontrer voilà je n'ai vu plein de
fois elle était toujours souriante saint
perdoux énergie incroyable toujours
souriante
c'est alors ariana nous a émus avec son
rire ses chansons et à la marque et une
génération
alors pour ceux qui la hait la
connaissez peut-être pas peut-être du
club dorothée agathe peut-être kelly
c'est vrai que c'était vous a fait une
petite compil et c'est vrai que le club
dorothée les cultes et ariane aussi été
culte regarde
[Musique]
oh
il
pas mal arpenté la ville à vous dire la
vraie à la recherche d'une pierre voix
d'anna 10 on n'était pas si c'est que ça
[Rires]
et le cap sur l'île turc de cet amas non
cadres
[Musique]
à
jacky je voulais venir ce soir et on
voulait tuer d'absolument pour que tu me
dises un mot quand même sur ariane c'est
vrai que toute l'équipe est extrêmement
triste je sais que jugeant que jean luc
azoulay ce matin qui a d'ailleurs twitté
qui était effondrée c'est vrai que ça
fait des années il a jamais lâchés dès
lors il vous a jamais lâchés jamais les
utilités incroyable c'est incroyable ça
fait 40 ans que je connais 40 ans que je
travaille mes équipes puisque ariane
travaille encore avec jean luc azoulay
donc oui et c'est vrai que je sais que
toute l'équipe vous étiez très soudé
c'est une vraie famille sont là on est
vraiment effondré moi je suis
extrêmement triste ccc et c'est vrai car
yann à l'été dans le club dorothée était
toujours pétillant elle était comme ça
et du bon sens exactement pareil alors
là la pétillante toujours super peps
très speed très drôle beaucoup d'humour
et voilà qu elle était comme ça et elle
était à l'arrêt et le club dorothée
après le club dorothée je crois qu'elle
était elle travaille aux côtés de jean
luc azoulay mur oui s'occuper un peu de
sa directrice artistique chez charge et
là oui exactement dans la boîte
aujourd'hui renouveler et elle est venue
nous voir sur le plateau aussi de touche
pas à mon poste et c'est un très bon
moment était venu le voir en 2014 avec
dorothée et on avait offert un jeu du
club dorothée et elle n'était pas
insensible au charme de jean michel mr
regardé et je kiffe ariane je maintiens
l'ouverture d'un bar à rien de jouer et
pas changé comme vous dorothée monsieur
ne vais pas changer tous ces gens tués
dans des maisons il vous plait ariane
jean-michel affaire
ces ensembles ariane si vous répondez
bien ne se passera rien pour jean-michel
vert si vous répondez mal sur la voici
la question oui dans quelle série est
apparu pour la première fois justin à
toute première fois c'était dans salut
les musclés dans salut les musclés juge
line vous êtes sûr vous pensiez sur
nantes ici je suis bien seul à bord
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que voilà je pense très fort
à la famille d'ariane à toutes les
personnes voilà qui ont travaillé avec
elle est-ce que ça c'est vrai que j'ai
vu plein de tweets ce matin cyril féraud
qui dit ariane toute notre enfance qui
s'envole on n'oubliera ni ton rire ni
ton sourire immense pensée pour eléonore
et et la famille il ya plein de gens qui
disent que c'est vrai que c'est toute
une claque tout une part de de l'enfance
de voilà de valérie bénaïm c'est une
part de notre enfance parce que ça
accompagné alors peut-être que les plus
jeunes ne s'en rendent pas compte mais
ça accompagné tous nos après-midis voilà
et c'était vraiment des compagnons de
route on a grandi avec ces personnalités
tourner tous les jours quoi 7 jours sur
cinq sont en effet mis leurs parents
mais c'est plus que ça il régnait sur
l'imaginaire de toutes les gauches
quoique mais c'est à dire que jacky de
choc était d'autant plus fort ce matin
c'est que l avait annoncé à quelques
années qu'elle était malade et puis
ensuite elle avait annoncé que ça allait
beaucoup mieux qui avait tant aimée sûr
qu'on pense c'est vraiment
qu'aujourd'hui elle vivait sa vie mais
qu'elle allait très bien ben non qu'on
avait choqué parce qu'on n'imaginait pas
que la maladie était revenue jeu
malheureusement oui vous vous saviez
tout ça vous savez bien sûr on ne sont
pas donc ce matin c'était un chauffeur
n'a vu le coup arriver du tout c'était
un choc vraiment énorme effectivement
c'est tout autre enfant souffrant soir
c'était c'est d'autant plus un choc que
il ya un an corbier disparaît alors et
alors en fait on peut donner une info il
y aura sur idf1 je crois une grande nuit
de souder les missions sont à venir où
on verra des images de darian des images
d'archivés de cet éminent du dessous
jacques est ce que tu as quelque chose à
dire ce soir un téléspectateur de mort
je suis très ému je te remercie
d'ailleurs invité parce que un mot
absolument sur ariane et qu'on fasse
chaussures elle est aujourd'hui parce
que c'est vrai que tu l'aimé énormément
de rencontrer trois quatre femmes était
très sympathique et en plus c'était
vraiment une amie on s'entendait
combien vraiment je suis battue ce que
j'ai à dire c'est extrêmement triste et
je vois là c'est ce sujet très ému quoi
voilà je vois là on pense très fort en
tout cas à sa famille a tout simplement
déçu si je sais pas un ami qui la
connaît très bien voilà tu pas demandé
rien mais que dorothée il a joint au
téléphone aujourd'hui qui est très
pudique était dévastée mais les
souvenirs d'elle
j'adore être pas pourtant les croissants
également on avait des trucs ensemble
tout elle faisait fi des l'airial je
faisais un savant fou c'était des crises
de rire sans arrêt son plateau et voilà
je vous étiez encore très proches très
proches lui ont envoyé moi mais on
s'appelait très souvent et voilà je suis
extrêmement quelqu'un de votre famille
en fait oui ce matin c'est ma famille
c'est ma soeur voilà merci jacky en toi
merci de nous avoir accès ou non et je
voulais dire on pense très fort à rien
et à toutes et bien sûr sa famille
surtout à ses proches merci mais je
pensais
[Applaudissements]